[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] em
[Music]
good good monday morning
you sexual
anarchist
happy [ __ ] valentine's day
he's gonna get their anarch on today or
tonight or this evening whichever
charlie kirk you little [ __ ] oh man boy
do we have a lot a lot to get through to
today
with the uh super bowl um the
republicans are [ __ ] pissed at black
people we're in the super bowl halftime
show
there's a
lot of black people in the super bowl
halftime show
they don't surprise at all like not even
a little bit they're all pissed off that
snoop dogg's smoking weed like what the
[ __ ] are you people talking about you're
just now mad just now just now mad that
snoop dogg's smoking weed before he goes
on stage
you people really are [ __ ] dumb
holy [ __ ] there's only one white person
in the entire halftime show and he
kneeled
oh man they're getting upset about words
upset about kneeling
they're really really [ __ ] butthurt
they're really [ __ ] butthurt
about who was in the halftime show
it's a leftist radical socialist cabal
in the halftime show what are you
talking about
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
they're all like they're all in their
[ __ ] 60s what are you
what are you morons yapping about
these people have been singing these
same [ __ ] songs for 25 [ __ ] years
you dumb [ __ ]
snoop dogg smoked weed
this this is their winning message by
the way this is their winning message to
[ __ ] millennials out there don't go
vote for democrats because they like
snoop dogg and dr dre and mary j blige
and eminem oh great yeah great
great platform to run on
it's fantastic
they really can't help themselves they
can't they can't do it they can't
[ __ ] manage to help themselves and
it's only like 12 percent of these
[ __ ] there's 12 in the country
this is not the majority of people
thinking this [ __ ]
most people watch the super bowl
halftime show and we're like that's
[ __ ] cool god damn i remember every
one of those songs from 15 20 years ago
25 some of them
and the racists out there like
bunch of n-words
dancing around at the halftime show
and then cheering on the game where
there's a lot of black dudes playing
football
this really this really is [ __ ]
we got to get tethered to some sort of
reality here we have to get tethered to
some sort of reality it's getting
[ __ ] ridiculous
that we have to have discussions in this
country
that snoop dogg snoop diggity dog snoop
d
d-o-d-g
smoke tweet before the half-time show of
course he did
of course he did no [ __ ]
oh
man no one even knows who won the
[ __ ] super bowl at this point
no one knows who won the halftime show
who won
who won
was it those rappers or was it the white
supremacist
it's literally the conversation i've
seen several tweets like what message
does this send what do you mean what
message does this send this sends a
message to all older millennials that
this music is badass that's what message
it sends how don't you [ __ ] know that
at this point
every [ __ ] person
from the age of 28 to 38 39
that that 10 years
their kids were looking at him really
[ __ ] weird in the living room like
why are you dancing to this [ __ ]
music
and you think it's some kind of
political message
even even eminem kneeling
even eminem kneeling is not a [ __ ]
political message okay
it's not political you [ __ ] make it
political you make it political
equality and equity and making sure that
black people don't get killed by cops is
just called humanity that's all it is
and the nfl apparently said don't
[ __ ] kneel eminem don't kneel
don't show cap support
and of course eminem and eminem style
says yeah okay i won't kneel sure thing
[ __ ] kneels and he then just knee
over like you know gets down on the knee
and then stands up [ __ ] stays
there he gets down and he stays there
and the reason why i think he stayed
there my personal opinion
is that he knew the cameras would like
cut away they're like cut away cut away
he's kneeling cut away he's kneeling but
if he kneeled long enough there's no way
they were going to be able to keep the
gamers off of them no [ __ ] way
and good for him [ __ ] him [ __ ] him
good for him he should have
there's no place no place for the nfl
roger goodell or anyone to tell pepsi or
anyone to tell [ __ ] eminem that he
can't take a knee
on the stage
this is really [ __ ] dumb
really [ __ ] dumb we have we have
people who were completely upset
completely upset
taking the social media gonna boycott
over him taking a knee in solidarity
for black people not getting killed by
police
and supporting caller colin kaepernick
and the people who are pissed off about
that are cheering the people who went to
the capitol to overthrow our [ __ ]
democracy and killed cops
killed them
with [ __ ] flagpoles with blue lies
matter flags on them killed them
beat them
think about it
think about it
that's where we're [ __ ] at that's
where we're at in this [ __ ] country
valentine's day 2022 the day after the
super bowl
and today is a day because it's
valentine's day is a day of sexual
anarchy what the [ __ ] does that even
mean
i mean i know i know what i i i mean i
think i know
i don't wanna you know i don't wanna put
too much out there but i think i know
what sexual anarchy is i think i know
maybe
but it's not the halftime show
what the [ __ ] is charlie kirk talking
about you punk ass little [ __ ]
sexual anarchy charlie kirk wouldn't
know sexual anarchy if it sat on his
[ __ ] face
as if sexual anarchy
would want to sit on his [ __ ] face in
the first place
this [ __ ] guy this [ __ ] guy
charlie kirk what the [ __ ]
you have got to be [ __ ] me
you have got to be [ __ ] me sexual
anarchy what why what was it i can't
figure out i can't figure out if it was
when 50 cent
you know was hanging from the ceiling
like a bat
and then he jumps down and he had
women dancing around him and shorts
i don't know and tight tank tops
i'm not sure like the [ __ ] the
[ __ ] music video to that song that he
was singing
excuse me 50 cent that song the 50 cent
was singing
and then
and the people dancing around him that
song if you go watch the official video
on [ __ ]
any platform youtube if you want
that [ __ ] video is way more
scandalous than anything you've seen at
the [ __ ] super bowl
and charlie kirk is just now upset
and i can't figure if it's that or it's
probably that mary j blige was actually
[ __ ] dancing and singing and he just
can't handle women
being out front and being billed
as entertainment
as if as if mary j blige was wearing
something more scandalous than
anything anyone's ever wore janet
jackson had her did a titty out i'm not
opposed to that
but she had her titty out on national tv
years ago that was a long time ago
you remember the justin timberlake
you know wardrobe malfunction yeah
[ __ ]
but he's just now charlie kirk is just
now waking up to this sexual anarchy
look she's wearing boots
she's wearing boots
her legs might be showing a bit
what the [ __ ] are you maybe it's maybe
it's the twerking that really [ __ ]
confuses charlie kirk
he gets all anarchy and his [ __ ]
britches when he sees women twerking
you [ __ ] alpha cucks out there
you [ __ ] alpha cucks really are a
bunch of [ __ ]
i'm talking to you ben shapiro charlie
kirk because ben shapiro's on the
[ __ ] oh sex is gonna ruin america
train
what do you think america is what do you
think is build on
come on you think our economy ticks
because
we don't want six
speaking of our economy
speaking of our economy
they want to shut down the economy now
they want to shut down the country shut
it down
shut it down shut down the whole country
shut it down
for two years they were yelling open it
up so that everyone could get coveted
and die
we killed a million people in this
country
because they had to have their economy
now that now that the vaccine is working
they want to shut it down
shut down the country lock up the roads
and the highways let me tell you
something hey truckers out there if you
think that it's such a good political
statement to make sure that no one can
go anywhere
that's a let me tell you something about
a winning platform for the republican
party do that you dumb [ __ ] make it to
where no one can drive anywhere i'm sure
they'll vote for that
i'm sure your constituents will be so
excited that they won't even be able to
[ __ ] function on the highways
and go places that they want to go and
go spend money in the economy like they
want to spend i'm sure they'll be really
[ __ ] excited to vote for you
who wants to lock up the economy and
lock up the roads
they bitched and bitched and moaned
about joe biden his first year supply
chains supply change as the former guy
says supply change
we need a supply chain
they bitched and moaned about supply
chains
for [ __ ] months
[ __ ] months they bitched about supply
chains and now all of a sudden lock them
up
we don't want supply chains anymore
because the economy is heating up
and it's becoming more and more clear
that the inflation that we have isn't
actually inflation it's corporate greed
that tony michaels has been talking
about talking about
false inflation for months
we need some trust busting here is what
we need
when you stop these people from price
gouging it's what it seems to be
it's not just inflation that's causing
prices to escalate prop with corporate
profits are [ __ ] skyrocketing
the stock market's way the [ __ ] up
and these people
who love the economy
and it's great great for business you
remember you remember that [ __ ] down in
texas
in 2020
i think it was about may or june
and that [ __ ] lieutenant governor
down there gets on fox news and says
[ __ ] old people they need to sacrifice
their lives so we can have our economy
it's more important that we have an
economy than they have their lives you
remember that [ __ ]
they'll make the sacrifice for us
i believe is his words i don't know
totally [ __ ] dehumanizing
people in texas and older people in the
country
totally [ __ ] dehumanizing them as if
they're pawns in our economy or
something and their lives are worth
tossing aside for a few bucks for that
profit
now that profits are high and biden's
going to take the credit in the 2022
midterms and possibly in the 2024
election
nope lock it up shut it down shut down
the economy you can't have this [ __ ]
and these fascists are trying to fund
this [ __ ] all around the world we see
them in canada doing this [ __ ]
you know it's fake [ __ ] outrage
they're trying to have a trucker
insurrection or something up there
their goal is not to stop the economy
their goal is to overturn democracies
that's what they're trying to do
and it's all funded by these [ __ ]
fascists
all of it
with their [ __ ] pal putin putin hates
democracy it's his [ __ ] enemy
we have some issues to talk about
there's some more oath keeper news
you guys have seen this
apparently there was conference calls
for the oath keepers
to deputize the oath keepers to
overthrow the government of the united
states
hopefully this week we can bring on
dakota adams again i've talked to dakota
to see if he'll come on
and give us his thoughts you guys know
we interviewed tasha adams and dakota
adams the estranged ex-wife and son
of the oath keepers founder
stuart rhodes
the eye patch guy
right
the seditious pirate
as it were
but we also have news
from some of the ones down in florida as
well
so the oath keepers are in that news
let's see what else do we have running
in the news today that we want to get in
the tweety tweets and the trendy trends
and the shitless
roundup
the
um
act that has to do with the trucker
thing trump russia's in the news it
looks like
kid rock is trending in parkland we have
the anniversary of the parkland shooting
at marjory stone stoneman douglas
high school
and still still nothing done to protect
children from being shot and killed
needlessly
from weapons
that are weapons of war in this country
matter of fact we've taken steps back in
some of these states some states forward
a lot of states backwards
these children are not safe in these
schools
but the main thing is
snoop dogg smokes weed
this morning
and mary j blige showing her thighs is
sexual anarchy
holy actual [ __ ]
holy actual [ __ ]
and i'm sure we'll have plenty of people
on today
that will want to have a few words about
republican messaging i think we're going
to have gabe on here in just a few
minutes
we're also going to have rachel
bitkoffer you guys know rachel
i think she's going to be joining us on
the road today
but she'll be joining us later on in the
second hour of the show because you know
we do a show every single weekday
monday through friday noon eastern 11
central ninth pacific
every single weekday two hours
we do this show
youtube twitter twitch
and then when we're finished with with
the show doing the live version because
we do it live this is really live i'm
talking i'm saying this [ __ ] right now
as we speak
you're hearing me word for word live
really live live live
but after we get done we download it to
all your favorite directories
all your favorite ones even the ones you
love the boycott
apple google
i heart radio amazon spotify
it's all right there
it's all right there you can go download
it
every single weekday noon eastern 11
central nine pacific
if you wanna support the podcast which i
know a lot of you guys out there want to
support and you're always in the chat
the chat is lively today everyone's um
hating nazis and hating white
supremacists
this morning
which i love
i love
but if you want to support the podcast
you can go to thetonymichaels.com or the
link in the bio
the tonymichaels.com there's a couple
merch stores there you can get a [ __ ]
hat
you can also donate to the podcast
upgrade fund
we are working on getting a few more
pieces of software to change the look
you noticed our look has changed a
little bit
it's changing just a little bit by a
little bit by little bit
that's thanks to our executive producer
and co-host gabe sanchez he does all
that i'm not going to take her over that
he does all the all the fancy artwork
but gabe does all that and we're going
to get some software to change how the
layout of the shitless roundup looks
even it's going to be kind of nice
it's going to be cool i promise
so working on that and we're working on
our sound we're getting some software
for some sound because we got to change
our sound some of the volume levels are
off and this and that
so we got it we got to fix some of that
stuff
but
we will keep go we will keep hammering
away at our democracy every single
weekday so go to thetonymichaels.com
if you want to support the show and if
you if you can't
that is fine support it by retweeting
liking commenting
spreading it around like herpes all over
the interwebs
all over the interwebs let's get to the
let's get to the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends how about we go to the
[ __ ] list roundup you sexual anarchist
start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
welcome to the [ __ ] list roundup where
we round up all the tweety tweets and
the trendy trends of today
and boy do we have some sexual anarchy
that we want to go through
holy moly
you can't believe the sexual deviants
that are running around this country
singing in super bowl halftime shows
what the [ __ ]
snoop dogg hat on a goddamn sweatsuit
what are you talking about sexual
anarchy he had on a [ __ ] it was a
badass sweatsuit by the way
badass sweatshirt snoop dogg had a
badass sweatsuit
i wouldn't look that good i mean who who
the [ __ ] who the [ __ ] can go
beside snoop dogg who the [ __ ] can go on
the super bowl halftime show
and pull off a [ __ ] sweatsuit
sexual anarchy give me a [ __ ] break
you dumb [ __ ]
charlie kirk let's get right into it i
want to go right to the uh the tweet the
tweet of the charlie kirk day
of course um i tweeted this it's it's
getting pretty big here let's let's make
this bigger i want you guys to see this
charlie kirk wouldn't know sexual
anarchy if it's sat on his face
that [ __ ]
as if as if she would sit on his face in
the first place
i'm guessing that sexual anarchy is a
she i would imagine i mean that's what i
would guess definitely isn't no [ __ ]
dude
these [ __ ] fragile white males like
charlie kirk oh
did you see did you see she showed skin
her shoulder was showing i'm so offended
i'm so offended that eminem kneeled
you [ __ ] break
we're gonna go to the charlie kirk
thread for sure for sure we're gonna go
to the charlie kirk thread
and just because [ __ ] them
i'm sure there's a plenty plenty of
jokes you know what let's jump right
into
the charlie kirk thread let's not waste
a lot of time here going through the
trendy trends and the tweety tweets
here's the charlie kirk thread
here we go
oh we're gonna be here for a while folks
so you might want to grab you a coffee
and a seat
we're gonna be in the charlie kirk
thread for quite some time here
ron says charlie kirk ran over his
wife's
bedroom and made her turn the half to
him show off
get in there
it's sexual anarchy on that show
don't be watching
[ __ ] turd
uh
how can anyone take charlie kirk
seriously really
i mean
sexual anarchy at a at a [ __ ]
football game
have you ever seen have you ever seen
the cheerleading squads
at football games at different football
games
like like just the cheerleading squad
alone has more sexual anarchy than what
was shown in the halftime show again
again
snoop dogg head on a sweatsuit he was
smoking weed before it
that's not exactly it's not exactly
sexual anarchy all right
here's a 50 shade says 50 cent and a
tank top
top turns
[Laughter]
and a tank top turns charlie kirk on
so maybe 50 here is is saying that
50 is maybe the thing that pushed
charlie kirk over the edge
really you got him got him hot and
bothered
got him hot and bothered
he's [ __ ] gay
he's [ __ ] gay
let's see here what does ty have to say
apparently charlie kirk didn't like it
when the monkeys playing cymbals in his
head started
[ __ ] walking
[Laughter]
oh my god
we're gonna we're gonna be here for a
while folks we're gonna be here for a
while
kate says charlie kirk got a boner
during the halftime show and he doesn't
know what to do
that's see that's where i need a sound
effect
oh my god this [ __ ] guy this [ __ ]
guy
now you know some are saying oh this is
all distraction people are distracted by
this people are distracted by this but
here's the thing here's the thing no
need no need to get all [ __ ] butt
hurt about people actually clowning
these [ __ ]
okay don't get butt hurt about these
people being clown
this is very important
we can we can clown these son of a
[ __ ]
and and focus on message as well
it can happen it's not that difficult it
really
isn't it really isn't we can do both at
the same time and frankly we should
clown these son of a [ __ ] because if
they if they believe if they believe
that this is a winning message
for the young
the young [ __ ] up-and-coming people
listen charlie kirk bitching about this
halftime show being sexual anarchy if he
thinks that's going to attract young
people to their side you are such a
[ __ ] bonehead and i would imagine
that charlie kirk is going to end up on
the bonehead of the week somewhere
either as a contestant or the [ __ ]
alpha cuck i would i would highly highly
highly doubt that he doesn't make
the [ __ ] bonehead of the week here we
go gabe says charlie kirk watching the
halftime show
i don't know if uh i don't know that's
him or his are his wien
about to explode because he's seen fitty
sand in the tank top
this is really [ __ ]
it really is [ __ ] dumb irish girl
says charlie oh
my zoom is not working this morning
charlie kirk over here
over there thinking 50 year old rappers
are causing sexual anarchy that's the
thing like these people are in their 50s
and 60s
these are not like young people like sex
drug rock and roll type [ __ ]
these are people and they were they're
not singing new songs
what are you talking about these songs
are like 25 years old 20 25 years old
sexual anarchy
where were you 20 25 years ago charlie
oh that's right
that's right you were still [ __ ]
getting your diapers changed you little
[ __ ] what does rick wilson say here who
saw charlie kirk idea for manga schools
going belly up before it started
apparently everyone you've seen
and this is actually charlie kirk news
other than the guy
the guy can't handle
a little bit of dancing before he gets a
[ __ ] woody
right
before he has to sneak away to rub one
off
charlie kirk look at this guy who would
[ __ ] this guy in the first place huh
have you seen this guy
you know i accused i accused the sexual
anarchy of not wanting to sit on his
face but [ __ ] it's like a dinner plate
with a couple with a couple peas on it
look at it he's got a saucer head with a
little bitty
and all his facial features are like
right in the middle
[ __ ] weirdo
if you if you read this article you
would know that charlie kirk's little
america first academy where he's trying
to he's trying to indoctrinate children
like literally do what they accuse to
kill a mockingbird of doing
aaron and we're going to indoctrinate
children into
nazi propaganda it's going to be
fantastic
that way we don't have any of this
sexual anarchy
he's just [ __ ] christ
they're trying their damnedest they're
trying their damnedest
to create
the hitler youth again like they're
damnedest really working hard at it
really working [ __ ] hard oh here's
george han um a video
snoop dogg smokes weed oh god this has
got to be good here we go
did you see the black people dancing and
smoking grass and having fun
oh my god
oh [ __ ]
george
after my heart george
after my heart
oh my god did you see the black people
uh this is really [ __ ] stupid this
messaging that they think is a winner
like that's the thing that gets me the
most
that's the thing that gets me the most
is they think this message is a winner
they're like yeah yeah sexual anarchy
black people bad we hate black people
singing and dancing at halftime shows
like we're and we're trying to win the
young vote
wow whoosh
whoosh no wonder they want to
indoctrinate these children in
elementary school
[ __ ] by the time they get them to high
school in college all these horny young
people like sex or anarchy we like that
give me some of that
the [ __ ]
sexual anarchy viking
death metal says charlie kirk watch
footloose and decided to be the villain
really honestly think about it
like
anything in in pop culture
that says who the [ __ ] bad guy is and
who is the guy you don't want to be on
their side they do that
like oh yeah anything we want to make
sure the the majority of the country
turns against us we want to do that we
want to do that
but you know i found it i found a uh i
found a video
uh on the internet
uh and and maybe maybe we'll we'll play
this
we'll play this video um on the internet
here
let's see
let's see here
we'll play this play this video on the
internet
you guys ready to see this video
and we'll play here
okay let's see let's let's see if we can
get it going here
[Music]
looks like there was some technical
difficulty hi i'm carly circ and this is
really news now
i gotta say patriots we live in
interesting times
i'm not sure if anyone actually watched
a super bowl last night but if you
didn't and if you can hear the sirens
now we're leading to an
anarchy-like state but i'll tell you
this the super bowl was an absolute flop
wow the crimes in america
you can just hear them now
now the thing that i found most
offensive was the halftime show and if
i'm being honest
it made me feel uncomfortable and if i'm
being truly honest it made me feel
uncomfortable
privately
this type of display should not be
allowed on television women dancing on
stage and exposing themselves for our
pleasure
that is neither american nor christian
like these musical artists unleash what
i call
sexual anarchy into the homes of
millions of innocent super bowl viewers
on sunday
on a sunday of all days really the
lord's day
what does the world come to hm
it's simple folks anarchy leads to
communism in a chaotic decline of
society
ergo if you have sexual anarchy
well then that would ultimately lead to
a chaotic decline of the nuclear family
the thing that we hold so sacred the
true measure of a successful person in
our country
so tonight
when you go home to your loving family i
want you to sit down with your spouse
and children and discuss the evils of
the nfl
because it's time we once and for all
banish this grotesque and unfair leak
from our american society
thank you
[Music]
well you heard it right there
a report from rnn
really news now
i don't know
we're having technical difficulty i
cannot hear what you're saying
there's too much crime in the streets
and we have to go to it i'm sorry i will
talk to you americans at another time
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
headlines
[Music]
under president joe biden the american
economy adds 467
000 new jobs in the month of january
thanks brandon
[Music]
[ __ ] em
[ __ ] em
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome welcome back
sorry about the technical difficulties
there
mute was on
some different things are going on i
think we have the correspondent back
from really news now
we'll find out what's going on with that
let's see if we can let's see if we can
make this work now and correspondent can
you now hear me yes uh we can hear you
sorry it looked like there were some
sexual deviants out uh in the streets
causing some issues with uh our
connection so i apologize to my fellow
american patriots how are you all that
that happens sometimes with all the
sexual anarchy going around so you gave
us a report there about the sexual
anarchy from the super bowl um were you
were you present at the super bowl while
all the sexual anarchy was going on
no you would you would not catch me
anywhere near
that super bowl
um i i caught some clips online i
watched from the um this safety of my
own home yeah um but let me tell you now
that uh
i wouldn't go anywhere near the super
bowl
why why wouldn't you go near the super
bowl
why would i not yeah what what what
about this super bowl makes it to where
you did not want is it this just a super
bowl or is it all of them
it was just a super bowl okay what what
specifically was it because it was in in
california or los angeles or was it
because who was playing what's what's
the reason why you wouldn't uh take an
assignment to report
is there something you know i was told
the musical artist was going to be
eminem yeah
um
and i later found out that it was not
actually
the m ms
it was eminem oh so so the the the
disappointment about the sexual anarchy
is that it wasn't candy sexual anarchy
it's that it was
um maybe human
sexual anarchy is that is that what i'm
hearing exactly okay so slim shady
disappointed you when you seen that it
was
the rapper eminem not the green eminem
yeah sexy boots yes and also uh miss
brown eminem
um yes a librarian well you know
you you have to give you you seem like
you get excited when you talk about the
um the librarian brown eminem
i mean would you not also um
well you know what it seems it seems
kind of weird that that that people of
your ilk
um find find that m m's should be sexy
but people at the super bowl dancing for
entertainment should not be sexy it
really is kind of backwards to me i i
don't see any way that would be
backwards uh i find that to be
completely linear in logical thought so
you think that candy should be sexy
but people should not be who are dancing
i think candy i think cartoons uh lola
bunny
right um
[Music]
you know
i don't see an issue with um
these
entities uh having um
a a as you put it as sexualized or uh
you know an appearance
that is in that way um i think that's
totally fine and i think that you know
if you do and you know i i you know i i
feel like you're gonna come at me with
this you just talked about how we
shouldn't sexualize things and how it's
un-american but i would tell you right
now if you look in uh the bible you know
st john's bible and you look in there in
leviticus 14 sections one through three
um you would see that even christ
himself said
um
look unto thou candy for it is
sexual it says it says that in in where
leviticus is that what you said yes it
talks about candy uh-huh and also uh in
luke mark uh and john
also there's a difference as well
different um
interpretations
of
uh
how jesus
spread
his
his
sweet his sweet
s semen sermon semen what did you say
uh
i i believe i believe i said sweet
sermon oh okay i don't know where you
are i misheard you i'm very sorry i
misheard you i would never those words
would never cross my mouth unless i were
giving some sort of
um biological uh course i know i know
that i know that um you know um jesus
turns most um evangelical christians so
do you identify as a as a evangelical
white fragile male excuse me a
white male is it evangelical
white is it strong as a strong male i i
do identify
weak weak is that what you said i i said
strong oh strong okay because i see what
you're trying to do here tony you know
it is some sort of like hit job you're
trying to attack me right now is this no
no i'm just i'm just trying to i'm just
trying to i'm trying i'm trying to get
to the truth here and i delivered the
truth you know and that truth is true
from god speaking through me to give you
the the the information that you need to
know about
the sexual anarchy in this country and
how we have devolved into a nation that
purely lives off of these sexual
temptations and desires have you ever
been to an nfl football game have you
ever been to one
i have okay
have you uh have you watched
some halftime shows during an nfl
football game like just any not just
this super bowl but any of them in
general have you ever seen
those super bowl or the the just the
regular is that the super bowl i don't
think that is an important uh
question or thing to answer
i i was just wondering if you'd ever
seen some of the cheerleading squads i
mean they're beautiful most of them
they're they're very very beautiful
women have you seen
the cheers for some of them like the
dallas cowboys possibly i don't know
what cheerleaders are
you don't have any idea what
cheerleaders are no honestly
this is the first time that i'm hearing
the word
cheerleader oh okay so this is the very
first time but you definitely know
what the green and brown sexy eminem
candy is apparently
yes okay well speaking of eminem's and
eminem the rap artist how did you feel
about eminem taking a knee during his
performance after he um
did his musical number there un-american
was what an american that was american
on a that was a complete
insult
to the flag okay so so it wasn't during
the national anthem so i'm very confused
why it's an insult to the flag if it
wasn't during the national anthem
because
the flag holds true over all of us at
all times it's like god
it sits there
heavenly father our heavenly flag sits
above us all 13 stripes and 50 stars red
white and blue
so this this also goes back to if you've
ever watched the football game you know
tim i know you know tim tebow you know
tim t he's a man of god yes right the
true man of god yeah yeah he he prays
during games when he scores you know he
does and you know what he does when he
does it he kneels on the field he kneels
are you against tim tebow kneeling
in the name of god oh okay but so so in
that case when the flag's flying and the
flag is always flying in that case not
so offensive but when eminem takes a
knee after his musical performance
definitely offensive and then america is
offensive it is an insult it is like uh
throwing dirt
in the eyes of america do you have do
you have any idea why he would kneel
during that point during his performance
i mean i think i know why but maybe you
know why he hired you know his
his you know so it's un-american to be
to be a little exhausted after a
performance is that what you're saying
listen i heard some lyrics from his song
about spaghetti and the sweater and his
knees were heavy so i you know it would
make sense why he might take anything it
seemed like he was a little weak and
exhausted
i think i think the reason why he was
taking the knee is to give solidarity
for for black people being killed by
police i don't know if you know colin
kaepernick is you know do you does that
name sound familiar to you colin
kaepernick a traitor
oh you think colin kaepernick is a
traitor
oh okay so so colin kaepernick kneeling
in solidarity for um black people being
killed by police is is is trade treason
as traitorous right i mean that
i'm i'm just uh repeating the words of
trump you know what oh so so trump is is
uh the the word of god on this is what
you're saying yeah yeah okay so so let
me ask you what about the trump
supporters who went to the capitol and
were carrying american flags and a lot
of times blue lives matter flags and
we're beating and killed a police
officer do you think that's offensive do
you think that's unpatriotic do you
think that's un-american do you think
that's probably a lot more significant
in our you know timeline that we have
here to
call someone a traitor i think they were
trying to overthrow the constitution in
the united states overthrow i think is a
little liberal of a word there tony i
think you're exaggerating so what would
the word be if it's not overthrow um it
looked uh from my account and also some
insider reports from fbi agents that
this was an inside job
it's an inside job of all of those
people were just actors
the the people who are the 750 political
prisoners that the republicans are
trying to get released are actors i
haven't seen any paperwork i've only
seen a number that uh
mayor garland has said so no your guys
your guys's mouth and [ __ ] really do
collide here when you talk out your ass
and your mouth because here's the thing
because you you always say two different
things i want sexy eminem with boots but
when mary j blige goes on the super bowl
and wears the sexy boots that's sexual
anarchy i want i want people
i love when people go to the capitol and
use american flags to beat and kill
police officers but eminem
eminem cannot cannot kneel
during a halftime show in solidarity
with black people being killed by police
officer with
with police brutality
you see how these things are kind of
opposite right do you no i don't i'm
just gonna tell you how it is tony uh
here at rnn we really do report on the
news that is happening the important
facts of the matter you know this isn't
some uh we're gonna cancel you we're
gonna we're gonna get rid of you we're
gonna
say that oh you said this or did that
you know no no no we are unfiltered true
americans at heart so you definitely
don't want cancer culture is what you're
saying nope nope no no no one should be
canceled is what you're saying no no
cancel culture no no i want to cancel
cancel culture okay i want to cancel
cancel so let me ask you with the super
bowl should because of what happened
with what you say is and you uh ben
shapiro charlie kirk is calling this
sexual deviance this sexual anarchy is
you as you say it
do you think
do you think that they should be
canceled for doing that on on live
television during the halftime show do
you think they should be canceled oh
they should not be able to get a job
ever again okay should not be able to
hold a concert venue or perform for
anyone ever again i mean
that's the style of the american trust
and the people
are you kidding me this is
an utter disgrace of just uh uh just an
insult like i said i mean you know we
paid these people to perform
at the show
and instead of just
doing what the nfl said you know we're
taking knees and we're shaking booties
and we're smoking joints
this is not what america was built on
this is not the america that we want to
have today right so just now just now in
this in this timeline right now right
just figured out you just figured out
that snoop dogg smokes weed so you want
to cancel him but you are going to
cancel cancer culture is what you're
saying you see how these two things do
not do not add up
nope
you're not sure
i i see them as completely separate
things
i would say that
your actions and these are consequences
like you guys like to say consequence
culture you know some people say it's
not cancelled culture it's consequence
culture but let me tell you
they made those choices and these are
the consequences that come from them so
so let me ask you one more thing because
a lot of people are are saying that the
reason why the right wing um i don't
know if you consider yourself right wing
or not or or maga right wing as in
correct wing if that's what you mean
oh correct okay well fine um we'll play
we'll play ball there so your right
wingers out there um are
it seems like it seems like the only
reason why they were upset about the
halftime show
is because the people performing were
black there was a lot of talk that there
was only one white person which was
eminem but all the other performers were
black they seem like they have a problem
with that is that a problem that you
have
you know i i don't feel like i should
comment on this um
this is one of those things that i've
already made very clear you know okay
i said you know they shouldn't have been
shaking their butts they shouldn't have
been taking knees they shouldn't have
been smoking joints these are the things
that we lead to a a
a a state of society we're going to have
a state of emergency is what's going to
happen you know we're going to need
someone to come in and correct the ways
so that we can get back to our true
american christian
you you mean like totalitarianism is
that what you're saying like authorities
i'm just saying whatever it takes to get
us
forward on that path oh okay so even if
we got to shut down the economy to do
that because i heard in l.a i don't know
shut it down tony i'm just telling you
right now i you know i support those
truckers up by canada you know they are
holding themselves true to their faith
and their ideology
what what what is their ideology exactly
with the canadian trucker that a
tyrannical government and and society
cannot tell them what they can and
cannot do with their body so this is
their moment to stand up and revolt or
or park and revolt does it work
sure because they're blocking they're
blocking commerce and they're they're
trying from my understanding sounds like
there's a supply chain issue right now
and it sounds like they
if they were given the right kind of
acknowledgement and freedom yeah they
would be able to be the heroes and they
would be able to fix this problem so the
supply chain seems to the supply chain
is is a is a funny thing because see
this is where the two sides of the coin
you guys strat on the [ __ ] fence on
this thing because so you had that here
in america i don't know you're here in
america but you're talking about canada
but here in america
we've been hearing the right wing [ __ ]
for the first year about supply chains
even the former guy your orange
mussolini jesus said supply change like
he wanted to change the supplies and i
don't know if that's referring to his
depends the supplies of diapers but you
know we won't go there that's but they
talk about the supply chains and now
what you they got to open up the supply
chains get them open they're open now
they want them closed you see how this
again you're you're doing two things
that don't sound the same
no
not at all
just because for two years we had we had
the right wing screaming about opening
the economy and now they're talking
about shutting the economy down right we
need to open the economy that is correct
and the only way to open the economy is
to let those truckers do what they do
best truck
okay so so what why why then would
shutting the highways down and stopping
all the trucks why would that open the
economy
how would that open the economy it's
pretty simple okay it sounds pretty
simple really complicated but go ahead
it's pretty sweet
right there is a blockage right now and
that blockage are vaccines okay okay
and vaccines you know people want to say
oh you know my body my choice you know
don't put that in my body
that is your right
now think of think of this blockage
right this vaccine this meant this
ideology issue here that's causing the
problem now if we were able to get rid
of vaccines we just wipe away vaccines
altogether imagine the flow
that would come through to help
improve supply chain okay how how does
how does 90 of canadian truckers being
vaccinated anything to do with the
blockage of vaccine you know that 90
percent of truckers are vex do you know
why they don't have mandates
in in
where you're talking about because they
don't need them because 90 of people are
already vaccinated they don't need
mandates you know that right you know i
don't know how they do things in canada
but clearly that's not america clearly
you don't clearly you don't know how to
do things in canada it seems like it
seems like you're confused did you see
the gofundme um and then they had
another gofundme type page get shut down
for their funding because it was a bunch
of fascist right-wing fascists raising
money to overthrow a government did you
see did you see they shut down the
gofundme and refunded all the money and
then shut down another fund me type
i did it was gofundme and gifts and go i
believe yeah gibson go yeah yeah
frozen honestly it's tyrannical coming
in and insane that you can't donate to
who you want to donate you know i i
believe that's uh it's a little bit too
far of a reach so when a private
platform a private fundraising platform
says you've broken their terms of
service um it's tyrannical is that what
you're saying that private companies i'm
just saying uh it's not fair
oh yeah so so not fair
equals tyrannical
in my book it does tony you know if you
don't get things how you want them to be
it seems unfair and that is not that is
not the true way of life that is that is
a christian wouldn't do that an american
wouldn't do that you know these are
things that i feel like are again too
reaching for the government we need to
smaller government less control let
those things happen on their own you
know so why are you foreign why why the
right wing then is forcing uh
school boards not not to
have their own
policies on mask and vaccines then why
if if you don't want big government why
is big government stopping
school boards small government why are
they stopping them from having their own
policies you have like in several states
florida missouri texas um there's
attorney generals in those states suing
suing those school boards those small
governments as you call them big
government big state government suing
them to prevent them from having
policies that they want
those those aren't those aren't small
governments those are what what are they
if they're not small governments they're
just a pot of people oh so so it's more
of the liberal woke mob that are running
schools exactly yeah and and the actual
small governments are the state-run
governments the ones that you know you
know got those r's behind them you know
we got desantis so what you're saying is
democratic state governments are
are not good
republican state governments good
democratic state governments are going
to be the demise of the american society
you know much like sexual anarchy yeah i
don't know how many ways i need to put
it here but i'm just letting you know
that that that type of uh
freedom or liberal agenda that you put
out there is actually going to be
something that brings us down as society
let me tell you our viewers
have to be super excited that you showed
up today to give us this report on the
super bowl halftime show and also to
give us your views
on sexual anarchy
i mean listen again i'm
don't shoot the messenger here i'm just
the person that is delivering the news
as to how it really is right now right
like really news now right this is this
is the thing that you're going to do
well well well carly cherk i appreciate
you uh that's your your name right carly
harley cirque a carly cirque i'm i
apologize i apologize i i just want to
make sure i just i just hope that uh you
know if i come back on the show later
that you'll get the name right you know
i just think it's only it's only fair
that you
are able to um
give me back that same respect that i
have toward you you know well i i wanna
i wanna say um i hope i hope you have a
happy valentine's day i really do and i
hope that you participate in all the
the um
the the sexual anarchy that you possibly
can with you and whoever your your
valentine is i will not be performing
sexual anarchy we really we really want
to make sure that on this valentine's
day that we have national sexual anarchy
no
no
i do not support that liberal agenda
you're pushing right now the woke the
woke mob out there definitely definitely
wants to have enough sexual anarchy to
go around you know what this interview
is over this interview's over i'm done
i'm done we're done you know what i'm
just going to say sexual anarchy needs
to go down
[Laughter]
all right well he obviously got a little
pissed off there so stay stay tuned stay
right here we'll be right back
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you annoyed by masks infringing on
your rights do you wish you didn't have
to comply with biden's communist mask
mandate are you tired of wearing masks
that actually fit your face
well now you don't have to be
introducing the droop with our patented
droop technology every mask is uniquely
molded to not fit your face just send us
a selfie and we'll have one of our
troopes mold the mask for you elastic
free thanks to the droop i don't even
need to pull my mask on anymore it just
sags that way the droop lets you
customize from a selection of pre-worn
masks lipstick stains included make sure
to order your drew today drew be the
spread you want to see in the world
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at twitch.tv slash the tony
michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
well i really do want to apologize i
didn't i didn't understand when we were
going to bring the uh
carly carly shirk in her shirt she
whatever his name was i didn't really
fully understand what his report was
going to be but obviously he's giving
the right wing stance which is uh both
sides of the fence they're completely
hypocritical on every single issue as
you know um they they want sexual they
want they want m m's to wear they want
eminem's to wear
um they're uh they're they're sexy boots
but they don't want mary j blige i have
a special guest with us now as you guys
know reporting from her truck hey rachel
how are you
i'm i'm good dude i'm the queen of
sexual anarchy are you the queen of
sexual antarctic did you start used to
me yeah did you get a chance to watch
the super bowl
i did are you kidding kind of [ __ ]
red what kind of question is that you
know i'm a true blue red blooded
american good good good did you did you
check out the halftime show or or did
you just couldn't handle all the sexual
anarchy dude oh no i feel so i i feel so
um i'm never going to recover i'm you
know you can ban all the books you want
now and now i know all about sex
right well you know you've already read
these books apparently but your your
great buddy charlie kirk kind of blew up
um on the internet uh on twitter by by
saying and i don't really understand
this i can't figure this out i don't
know what part some people are saying
it's because there was shoulder shown
some people are saying that 50 cent was
in the tank top um is the reason why is
the reason why charlie kirk just
couldn't handle all the sexual anarchy
that was happening
can you figure out what what the sexual
anarchy was that he's seen because i
can't figure it out
yeah you know i want to remind everybody
charlie kirk's 28 years old
the [ __ ] grew up on victoria's
secret catalogs and that angel
commercial i mean so you tell me tony
what could it be about those individual
skin that they were showing that might
have sparked charlie's outrage i i don't
think it was the butt cheeks dude right
well you know you know it it does seem
it does seem a little far-fetched that
to me that uh charlie i'm a nazi kirk
you know as i call him um would would be
so so
so offended by the this super bowl
halftime show which is hilarious he's
like he's like a 90 year old man like a
like a 20 year old's body right yeah
i'm really lucky i'm like so old i
remember when janice uh uh when uh
what's her name's uh jackson yeah yeah
jackson's boob popped out and the
scandal i mean charlie [ __ ] he wouldn't
he'd have to get therapy if that
happened if he saw titty
maybe maybe maybe the maybe the titty
affected him in a certain way and he
just he suppressed some of those
memories with the therapy that he got i
don't i don't know i don't know
conversion type therapy or what oh no
but man if i had time and my name was
gabe sanchez
a water boy shout out about movies with
that i'm just saying
it is it is absolutely insane that that
this is this is where their messaging is
that they think that like the thing
that's going to speak to millennials and
even like jin's ears is that
hey we can't have rappers singing 25
year old songs and they act like these
are like new songs and like new artists
like these these people are in their 60s
that were singing at the halftime show
like what are you talking like
let's talk about that by the way like
what the [ __ ] are they drinking up there
down there in hollywood tony because
like i want to look like that when i'm
60 for sure
you know i was talking about this
because snoop dogg and and here's the
thing
of course they're really [ __ ] their
butt hurt that he was smoking as if they
just found out that snoop dogg smokes
weed which is really [ __ ] weird
that they're like oh he was smoking weed
like he's [ __ ] wind doesn't he he's
snoop dogg
he's constantly smoking it takes a
lifetime pot smoker to pull off threads
like that purple [ __ ] suit he was
rocking right that sweat suit
nope
show up no one else could show up and do
a hammer
in a sweatsuit
i had to go out and like wrap macklemore
right after that you know because those
threads are sweet
come on dog speaking of that like stoop
dog you were saying something must be in
the gin and juice because snoop dogg
like he looks the exact me and my wife
were talking about this
he looks exactly like you can tell dre
is aged right
mary j blige she she's aged 50 cent as
age same with eminem but snoop dogg
looks the exact same as he did 30 years
ago like he i don't know what it is and
tony you'd be proud to know like you
know when you've given every man like us
like you know access to a good rolodex i
start using that [ __ ] someone remember i
talked to someone from hollywood i'm
like what the [ __ ] are you guys doing up
there man what is it give me some of
that [ __ ] i want it i want to look
20 years younger than i do right now
that's right what's in the gin and juice
snoop dogg what's it must be the chronic
that he's smoking it has to be oh that's
what they're so upset about is he smokes
the weed he looks that young
so let's go because i know i know
everyone wants to know strategic outrage
and everyone thinks that this is kind of
like a joke how we clown them but this
really is part of their messaging like
charlie kirk just got off a really bad
week where he lost a big fundraising um
for his nazi academy excuse me his uh
his for his america first academy where
he's trying to indoctrinate children
like they're really trying really hard
to get a lot of rich people involved
into doing the thing that they accuse
the left of doing right of
indoctrinating kids and um and this is
part of their so is this like do you
think that this is his way
of messaging to young people i mean i
can't figure this [ __ ] out because ben
shapiro's on this train this morning too
about this
that's because like the crt myth you
know that they're gonna wedge in the
fall like a component part of that is
porn okay so like yes there's race
they're going after all of these black
authors
but they're what they're hiding their
racial racial motivated [ __ ] behind
is this idea of sexual innuendo right so
like they feel like if they what they're
trying to do is set up this entire frame
that like you know democrats want to
poison your children and turn them into
hedonistic you know drug-using party um
you know sexual deviants right and so
like that there's like there's nothing
like comes out of kirk's timeline
shapiro's timeline that chick sarah
iscar on uh george stephanopoulos show
that i watched yesterday when they get
on tv when chris christie gets on tv the
dude has a [ __ ] mission dude and
that's a messaging mission right not to
go and have a conversation it's about to
get [ __ ] done right so when charlie kirk
sent that tweet out i immediately
recognized
and part of this component attack on
education to come privatize and make
nazi academies and if somebody doesn't
make that point to these suburban
parents oh you know this is what they
mean they want to make nazi academies
for your kids right turn their little
kitchen breakfast marks and you know
have a police state like we're we're
gonna be in trouble so you know because
they really are so good at at making a
messaging garden grow
well yeah well i mean they've done this
for years with with the sex and the
video games you know it's always the
same old [ __ ] that they recycle right
and it's always it's always to get back
to this
us and them right whatever that means
and it's it's it's to make sure that
there's a superior person and and how
that superior person is going to react
to certain parts of culture right and
and and i think it's interesting that
you make you make the point that they
they're trying to make the the older
the older artists black people
performing at the super bowl some kind
of sexual thing which
honestly when i watched it like
especially the most sexual parts which
mary j blige had on like the night the
high boots and she was beautiful she was
beautiful did a fantastic job but you
compare that to
to tucker carlson talking about how they
took the sexy boots off the m m like
those two things don't [ __ ] match
like what are you talking about you
can't have one and not the other and
then you think well what are what else
is the sexual the sexual anarchy and you
go to the 50 cent part of it because
that when he's singing his song there's
a lot of women dancing around him that
has short shorts on they have like tank
tops on
but if you actually go back and you look
at the the official music video for that
song
those women are way more scandily
dressed
during that halftime show and i don't i
don't think that it was intentional or
unintentional or pepsi are the producers
of the hash time shows part to make it
sexual or non-sexual you know i don't
think that really played into what they
were trying to do with the show right
like that that wasn't the overall thing
the theme was hey there's a lot of
[ __ ] millennials between the age of
28 and 40 that are gonna [ __ ] love
this music oh [ __ ] and they're gonna be
dancing in their living rooms and their
children are gonna be looking at him go
why are you dancing like that like like
that was the goal it had nothing to do
with sex or anything it was it was to
sell pepsi to millennials that's what it
was about that's what it was about
managed dude i mean i would hope enemy
is killing it on the dl's today on apple
i'm sure that that album has gone viral
because i think a lot of these youngins
have never heard that and that's right
you know that's right yeah
people need to understand tony about
entertainment let me just make this
clear because when i found this fact out
i was like and nothing shocks me but
this shocked me i was watching one of
those histories of the 80s shows on cnn
and it was talking about mtv and i you
know i kind of remember when mtv first
became available at least to us but like
that was a little bit late like they
they started the germination seed in the
70s and michael jackson could not get on
mtv when they when he first wanted to be
put on mtv the executives were wary
about including a black artist right in
1980ish
on mtv michael jackson guys and like of
course they ended up doing it right did
you get thriller and bad and all these
great um mj videos out of the deal but
they had they were hesitant because they
thought white america will bulk if we
have a black artist on this and now it's
20 20 it's 40 years guys like you know
so it's not that i'm still alive
right
this is in my lifetime where they were
ahead of serious conversation so here's
the thing with kirk if that had been you
know what's her name carrie underwood
and she had boobies bouncing and she
should have a kid popping out and he'd
be fine
right well yeah absolutely
he's just he's just trying to utilize
look at the scary black folks and their
sexual gyrations you know well i mean i
mean you you go all the way back you
said
michael jackson who's known as the king
of pop you go back to what they know as
the king of rock and roll who is elvis
elvis elvis was gyrating and they
hesitated to put him on tv because of it
but it was much better for him to sing
black music because elvis sang black
music
and put him on tv as a white person
singing black music than the black
people singing the black music because
they couldn't do that either right
way back then so like this is part of
this whole [ __ ] that they're trying to
stoke this fascist [ __ ] this right-wing
[ __ ] um and i i agree with you and i
think it's not to be ignored you know a
lot of people like oh you're amplifying
their voice you're giving them credence
by talking about them like you have to
clown them you have to show america that
this is what they want
yeah guys if we don't talk about their
crazy no one else is going to do it for
us
well yeah well i mean it is insane to me
how many racist white people and i'm not
because i don't think what charlie kirk
said was overtly racist he definitely
has the racial undertones like you're
saying but there were people on twitter
like just being outright just straight
racist they didn't not care i don't know
how many accounts were probably banned
yesterday
after the halftime show but there was
probably a lot of counsel suspended for
saying the [ __ ] that they were saying
but but the the crazy part to me
about this
is that
they're okay with black guys
playing on the field and cheering for
the black guys on the field playing the
football game and that kind of
entertainment but they're not okay with
black people singing during the halftime
show they're not okay with that kind of
entertainment and i i'm just wondering
what people yeah listen tony if you've
hit something really important there
okay because it's that is that
intervening variable of team right so
like they're okay
they'd be fine if we brought out some
black artists that like you know we're
republican i'm sure there's like one of
them on the d-list somewhere
like that like you know i mean like
obama right like they're the like the
backlash to obama is racial but it's
conditioned on not being on team right
so this in group out group hostility and
that's why you can have successful
people like herman cain or whatever
right so like when we talk about racism
like we're not talking necessarily and
not often talking about the kind of
virulent uh racism that that was the
stasis of the nation through the 60s
okay what we're now talking about i
would call is more unconscious or
implicit
types of racism that condition how we
see [ __ ] and we would have seen all
white people do the same dance you
wouldn't heard [ __ ] from charlie kirk
about it
right well and and i've made this point
before that i think people need to
understand about fascism because we've
talked about it me and you on this show
and and we've talked about it privately
even that when fascism comes
you won't have the nfl the way you see
it there won't be the nba there won't be
entertainment the way that you know it
like they fascism will not only try to
get rid of black artists but try to get
rid of all memory and you being able to
listen to them at all like that music
that you heard and you love and you love
to dance too the fascist will try to
make sure that you do not have access to
any of that and we see it in the book
banning we see it in the book banning we
see it in charlie kirk at [ __ ] trying to
have nazi schools to where they erase
all semblance
of of black culture because that's what
they do is
well that's what they did in i mean in
germany what really made the [ __ ]
notable that they did with the nazi
party as it rose into prominence
especially driven by goebbels who was a
once in a lifetime and he's an evil
genius but he was a love once in a
lifetime like elon musk kind of level
innovator and what his innovation was
was psychological
manipulation through propaganda at a
grand scale right and so like you know
in terms of of um like germany's aims
they did not just aim to set like a
fascist regime into government they
thought the culture of germany was
headed down the the pooper because it
was the roaring 20s people are drinking
women are starting to have sex outside
of wedlock and starting to ask for
more political freedom in fact they
enfranchised women right before the rise
of the nazis okay so like you know
the the wiping of culture when they took
the museums they whipped out all of the
impressionist art from these museums put
in only nazi approved artwork really
people i urge you to go read the beast
garden of the beast by um
um oh god what's his name eric larson he
wrote also wrote the splendid in the
vial on churchill great
way to understand when this these
changes start to come and some of them
already are coming we're watching them
come right now you're going to
understand like why we're in a crisis
and the biggest crisis of all is getting
people to see the crisis
well and i i think even this trucker
convoy shut down the economy type [ __ ] i
think this plays into that message as
well even though it does like how in the
hell can can sexual anarchy play into
that shutting down the economy like well
what do you think anarchy is like
they're for anarchy they're just not for
the sexual type they want anarchy we
want to shut this down we want to shut
which is really funny because they've
been bitching about supply chains and
opening up the economy now now the goal
is to shut it all down hell yeah they
they want to win [ __ ] right so how do
they win [ __ ] they keep inflation and
they can complain and be uh you know
call biden bite inflation right i mean
we know is that i know exactly
everything they're going to do in the
fall exactly how they're going to do it
and we have to meet this moment with
fire
so what fire do we give let's talk about
the fire because i think that's
important to not just add the
conversation about what their message is
but how do we not not just combat it
because we need to combat it but we also
need to have something of our own to
make sure that that our quote-unquote
propaganda that's always a bad word but
our propaganda our message is
filled with truth but also getting a a
message out there that applies to all
these situations because for him to call
uh something that happens sexual anarchy
he's blanketing this message right
because he he can say that and it
blankets anything because we're like
what the [ __ ] does that mean so we need
to make sure that we're doing this where
we have this national blanket message
that can be applied to any issue and
make sure that it's in a way that is
pro-democracy and anti-fascist so how do
we do that how do we combat them but
also have our own message of pushing it
out there and getting that strategic
outrage as we talk about
yeah i mean the real thing is
replication right so like they have this
decisive infrastructure advantage in
their right-wing media ecosystem which
is much more than fox it extends into
local press local newspaper local tv
i think she lost signal
that is but how do you replicate or get
around or deal and work with what you
have right and what we do have is a lot
of media that is currently
not centralized not focused on attacking
the republican party or highlighting the
republican party's crazy wants to spend
their time having substantive debates
about interesting and
really critical policy and what i'm
telling people is we all need to
practice strategic outrage and
understand that if you have a platform
of any type you're also influencing
others and you can use that platform to
shape language get people to stop
calling it a trucker rally and call it
something else because it's not truckers
right it's an insurrection it's an
insurrectional
right so stop i mean anytime
and the media loves this like convenient
[ __ ] so like jan six instead of the
republican party's ongoing and you know
multi-faceted coup plot right right uh
trucker instead of you know um
anti-vaxx you know white supreme i mean
these are nazis at these things right
so like they you know you serve them up
something like trucker rally and then
everyone will tweet it everyone will
talk about it we're not we're not
helping ourselves in that right because
because we're we're using their message
to try to form our message which is
exactly the opposite of what we need to
do um because speaking of nazis in this
this trucker this trucker thing in
canada the the crazy part to me is
gofundme is like nope you cut off
we know what you're doing and and it's
not fun it's not funded by people in
canada it's like 90 percent of truckers
in canada or actually vaccinate that's
why they don't have to actually have a
mandate which they're bitching about
something that doesn't exist and the
reason why they doesn't exist because
they don't need it like when over 90 of
people are vaccinated you don't need a
mandate that's not a thing that you need
because it's a it's a done deal at that
point i mean you're talking about less
than 10 percent who gives a [ __ ] like go
go do what you want to do you know you
don't have to drive a truck and go do
something else
protesting the policy that's right right
well i mean that's just that's just the
[ __ ] excuse right right that's the
sexual anarchy that's the sexual anarchy
component of it right
that's the little message the little
nugget that they need to to cause chaos
to try to have an insurrection and
overturn democracy because that's really
what they're attacking at this point is
they're not attacking the economy
they're not attacking supply chains
they're not attacking the mandate
they're not they're really attacking
democracy and it's these these these
other actors out there that definitely
do not like democracy that don't want it
here don't want it there they don't want
it anywhere because democracy breeds
anti-fascism right like it breeds it
like that's that's what it inherently is
is anti-fascist when you have democracy
so
but they're trying to overthrow these
governments but more than anything
they're trying to spread this message
that democracy bad democracy doesn't
give you good things democracy give you
bad things like is the message that
they're trying to send so how do we how
do we as pro-democracy people to fight
back on putin's message because that's
where all this trickles down from that
[ __ ] guy i mean jesus christ we have
the entire [ __ ] republican party
being putin's puppies here in america
act acting as if oh well putin wins that
that's a biden loss so that's good for
geo horrible for america horrible for
america
they don't give a [ __ ] at this point
because fascist state better
better
that that is what our goal is no matter
what even if we have to support a
foreign actor who would definitely
definitely be our enemy in any other
circumstance we have to be his friend
because it it gives us the power to
overturn biden's tyrannical whatever the
hell they're talking about whatever
exactly
yep exactly i mean that's pretty much it
tony and you know at the end of the day
like we don't have we don't have a big
ass media system that we can set uh on
one wheel and have it hum but we can
replicate it as best as we can by
teaching people the importance of
language specificity in language when
you're bitching about congress what you
mean republicans in congress better say
republicans dude right average
person doesn't understand why gun
control isn't passing why climate change
isn't passing they think it's you they
think it's us right we have to tell them
you don't have the [ __ ] you want because
the republican party is blocking it and
they intend to do worse to you i think
you tweeted out uh several days ago and
i'm going to get this completely wrong
but you said basically the energy needs
to be turned around of
democrats didn't get anything done that
it's republicans fault that democrats
didn't get anything done and we need to
turn that message in and aim that
message that direction very quickly for
the 2022 midterms um you know i i i say
so many times to people that you know
joe manchin and kirsten cinema are not
running for senate they're not running
there's not a race in their race this
this cycle so to to con continue to
[ __ ] about them it's not going to do
any good we can go win ohio we can win
florida we can win those seats
and that's that's what the message is
against um cinema mansion if you want to
have it let's go win those seats that we
don't have and increase our majority in
the senate um because
democrats are the only one that are
going to deliver voting rights at this
point we watch every single republican
vote against them because they want to
destroy our right to vote they want to
destroy women's liberty i mean they want
to destroy everything for that matter
because sending those cuckoo because
like you know for i mean look at mark
kelly right i mean he's in the same
state he's a democrat too right being a
democrat doing just fine right right
she had no electoral incentive to do
what she was doing and nobody has any
idea what the hell she her calculus is
but when it comes to mansion dude people
think oh mansion doesn't want to do it
because he's got coal money and i mean
i'm sure all that [ __ ] matters dude but
at the end of the day you take joe
manchin and put him in a biden 35 state
he's voting yes on climate change [ __ ]
that's right
he'd have done
[Music]
who are listening to my voice right now
and that's because of the republican
[ __ ] party the republican party
divested itself from governing the
nation about a decade ago
figured out they could still win
elections regardless because of better
marketing and um you know how they
campaign and they've never looked back
right so like when they come into a
congress in 22 when they came in in in
um you know in the past their objective
is to
is to use their power to thwart
your agenda in every possible way that
they can if that means stealing a
supreme court seat fine that means
canceling democracy fine that's who
you're up against you're not fighting
democrats you're not fighting
corporations
lobbyists you're fighting the republican
party and it is time that we all put our
full trained you know verbal arsenal
towards that goal right well because i i
think if we don't we if we don't have
the strategic outrage to make sure that
democrats can deliver to
prevent republicans from destroying our
democracy um we won't save it so it's
very important that we aim it in that
direction and i think we have a lot of
good things working for us um i i think
i think there's a lot of good things
happening out there but we have to stay
focused we can't just say oh well
everything's gonna fall into place we
have to continue to push we have to stay
pissed we have to go [ __ ] vote and
and i don't just mean mark a ballot i
mean we have to get engaged in these
races and do that thing
yeah and i argue that we should help
people get to that moment and feel that
way by a full-on napalm of the gop i
mean we should prosecute the republican
party on climate change first off it's
their like oil and gas [ __ ] that killed
the environment then when they found out
they were killing it they decided to
invent climate change as a hoax right
and that was all lobbyist money and it
was the same people that did uh doubt
about smoking and cancer okay that's who
brought you climate change as a hoax
that's not organic either that was a
strategy that they financed deployed and
did and it ended up turning like there
was never like not a partisan divide in
environmental data now it's like this
okay that's what they did and they
because of that and their continued
obstruction even as the emergency has
become much more obvious uh you know
these this future generation gen z jet
millennials they need to understand we
didn't get here by accident and we're
not getting out of it unless we roll
over the republicans
right well because that's the only
option that we have because they're not
they're not they're not going to stop
they're not going to stop vote for that
[ __ ] never dude so you older have to get
them out of the way or
you know just don't expect [ __ ] you
can't do [ __ ] with this government
unless you have enough votes in the
right places to do it and you know like
i said joe manchin is the last democrat
that will ever serve in the state of
west virginia okay because he has to get
30 people almost 30 percent of the
republican vote to survive in there
right so
no one can get that [ __ ] like 10 is the
cap so manchin getting that extra 20
is a function of mansion himself and
once he's gone that will completely turn
red and it will not elect a democrat at
least without another historic
realignment um intervening into american
politics which cyclically could happen
in 50 years but in the in the meantime
that west virginia you can't primary joe
manchin he doesn't he's afraid of
republican voters not you
right right well that's why he's doing
what he's doing yeah because he has to
get the vote right no [ __ ] he's a
senator
he's 30 it's a 35 plus trump state right
it is west virginia
he was 65 35 or 70 30 or something like
that dude you know you know before we go
but i want to ask you one more thing
about the january 6th and some of that
but speaking of the the west virginia
doesn't it doesn't it floor you that the
messaging that that democrats could have
to attract what would be known as
conservative voters on issues like
people in west virginia they want decent
[ __ ] wages like they don't want to go
bankrupt because of a [ __ ] health
care bill like they want they want
decent jobs right like they want their
families to have a decent way of life
they don't want to be [ __ ] broke like
the exact that's the exact opposite of
the republican message
somebody's got to come in there and say
look republicans have been controlling
your ship for 20 years where's all your
[ __ ] right exactly yes oh wait a minute
you have less than you had 20 years ago
what a surprise let me tell you what
they did to steal all your [ __ ] okay
like that's the kind of messaging you
need you can go into west virginia all
[ __ ] day and say oh look this
provisional buildback better pulls at 60
well then re-poll that west virginia
audience and then pop in democrats want
to do this republicans want to do that
and you watch that support plummet dude
right right
they want that but unless you understand
the power the intoxicating power of
hyper partisanship you are never going
to be able to get that through to that
audience and that brings me that
hyper partisanship brings me to some of
the news that is coming out of the
january 6 with some of this um seditious
conspiracy we've seen the oath keepers
they were having
[ __ ] conference calls apparently um
to plan to plan this thing yes and and
and everyone's wants the january sixth
select committee to arrest people like
right now which is not how it works um
but but and i've been saying for several
weeks and even months that hey the
january 6 select committee is going to
tell a story here and if democrats and
you out there democratic voters do it
correctly we can actually use that as a
message of what they're going to do with
our country if they take back power
right like all the things they wanted to
do that they were not successful at they
are going to try to do again and i i
think it's important for people to
remember because i did an interview with
tasha adams which is the exchange
ex-wife of stuart rhodes the founder of
the oath keepers i also his son joined
us
and
their their view of it was is that the
oath keepers
kind of did a 180 for donald trump right
like their entire organization was in
the exact opposite direction of what
they actually did with this seditious
conspiracy and a lot of it was to
protect stewart rhodes himself um it has
a lot to do with the bundy ranch and i'm
hoping i can have him back on but the
point that i'm trying to make here is
that these people were willing to go
against their entire their entire life's
work of beliefs to maintain power for
this this idea that one authoritarian
could give them what they want like this
is fascism 101 this is the sexual
anarchy [ __ ] all rolled into one and we
can actually use the story that january
6 select committee is going to tell over
the spring and summer as it a little by
little by little like we can let the
american people know who don't know now
i have a friend of mine the other day
rachel i was talking to him about the
the white house destroying documents and
like what are you talking about what are
you talking about i have no idea what
you're talking about
i keep yelling at twitter i'm like dude
normal people who even vote have no
[ __ ] idea any of these headlines and
if we don't find a way to tell them what
has happened and force them to see it
right that distribution and isn't
something you can just you know
we'll just dial it in [ __ ] it you know
no we gotta get him to look we gotta get
him the information get him to look okay
and this is no small task so i'm gonna
close out by saying this you're
absolutely right getting liz cheney to
run that committee adam kissinger
they're running that [ __ ] like a
republican committee except for it's a
republican committee for the first time
with an actual scandal to investigate
because keep in mind usually they're
just making [ __ ] up right so like in
this case the meek is just as rich as
the politics and liz cheney is counting
on somebody to be there to hit the ball
that she's gonna serve up once these
committee hearings start our system is
not geared to hit the ball and that's
why you see me every day on twitter
yelling hey we've got to get this [ __ ]
fixed and we got to do it by april 1st
right well and i think i think we got
good opportunity and we can do this
thanks for reporting from your truck
today what kind of favorite place on
earth dude
it was i i really i wanted rachel on
mondays it's kind of a thing we've been
doing so i appreciate you joining us
even from your truck and we'll have you
back next week to talk about whatever
these [ __ ] psycho
fascists do over the next weekend
because they always seem to serve us up
the the ease of messaging over the
weekend um
we certainly don't lack for material to
work with no
absolutely absolutely not rachel thanks
for stopping by we'll see we'll see you
next week um hopefully we'll be able to
bring in maybe next monday as well if
you're not too busy thanks rachel
everyone stay here we'll be right back
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
headline
[Music]
under president joe biden the american
economy adds 467
000 new jobs in the month of january
thanks brandon
[Music]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
thanks for hanging in with us
we always like to have rachel this offer
on
he's talking about strategic outrage and
messaging
everyone loves rachel
here on d tony michael's podcast
we love having her on too to kind of
break down
what these [ __ ] are saying and how we
can combat it with messaging in the
strategic outrage i think it's
completely completely relevant
that we do that um because i i think i
think the the more we tick along here
uh in the spring and summer like
rachel's saying we got till april really
get this machine going where we have
this messaging machine
and i think it's going to be right
around the time that we start to see
these public hearings come out because i
was i was talking to a friend the other
day i was talking to a friend and he had
no idea about this document story not
not about the toilets or the eating
documents like you know like like the
the crazy [ __ ] that the funny ass [ __ ]
right that's the [ __ ] crazy
just the far out [ __ ] timeline [ __ ]
right that we can't even believe that
this is reality that this guy was
[ __ ] eating notes and documents and
he was flushing [ __ ] documents down
the toilet
but the fact of the matter is that there
was 15 boxes
of documents that he took from the white
house some of them top secret but they
were also trying to destroy them the
national archives reported that they
were taping them back together when the
january 6th select committee was
receiving some of these documents they
were taping them they'd been torn them
up they were tearing them up
when i told my friend that he's like who
who was tearing them up you talking
about the people that ransacked the
capitol i'm like no what are you talking
about because i mentioned burn bags too
they said did you see the reports about
the burn bags of documents he said you
talking about the in the the january 6
when they went to the capitol i'm like
no
no i'm talking about trump i'm talking
about the administration the white house
was
putting documents and burn bags to burn
them they were destroying documents not
only that they stole them
he [ __ ] stole them
15 boxes worth of [ __ ]
of course some of those letters were
like the kim jong-uns in the the the
[ __ ] sharpie gate poster board which
i think he was going to try to sell
those
you know this guy doesn't give a [ __ ]
about that so he wanted to sell that
[ __ ] you know they're into this nft [ __ ]
now and melania trump selling nfts and
defrauding charities apparently
but that's another story but this but my
friend who is not a dumb person
and who knows things like about
government and he they vote they [ __ ]
vote like every single election they
[ __ ] vote
didn't know
didn't know the story about the [ __ ]
top secret documents had no [ __ ] clue
i'm like what
why why didn't you well the reason why
is because they hadn't heard it they
didn't see it
and see it you know tom brady retiring
was a much bigger story that day
and donald trump stealing top secret
documents
and this is what rachel's talking about
when she says that the the the apparatus
that the right wing has created over the
last 30 years with their media
organizations not just fox news i mean
that's a big one but also oan newsmax
but they're right-wing talk radio
they have a huge network and it's not
just the big names either like charlie
kirk ben shapiro dan bongino sean
hannity what used to be ruslan ball
rest in no piece that [ __ ] at racist
piece of [ __ ] at vile [ __ ] a
piss on his grave
but listen
they haven't they have a [ __ ]
infrastructure that they have created
over the last 30 40 years
to pump this information into these
people's [ __ ] skulls
that's what we're up against because
when you talk
if you ask a [ __ ] about emails
oh my god emails and classified emails
they [ __ ] lock her up lock her up
they they would talk about hillary and
benghazi and emails for [ __ ] days
they would know all kinds of crazy ass
[ __ ] about [ __ ] emails and private
servers and
and pizzagate and all kinds of [ __ ]
crazy ass q anon [ __ ]
you ask him you ask him about 15 boxes
of top secret documents that the cheeto
dust mobster stole from the white house
nope never heard of it what the [ __ ] are
you talking about
he was he was flushing documents down
the toilet he was eating him that sounds
made up yeah it sounds made up because
it's him it's he's a [ __ ] cartoon
he's a buffoon of
course
it's hard to even parody this [ __ ]
trust me we try we try and
sometimes we can't even [ __ ] do that
you've seen the parody that we just had
and it was difficult to parody them
because
you can't take it up a notch they're
already there they're there the fascists
are already there you can't parody them
but it's important that we get the
messaging across and it's not just like
oh what do we say now what do we say
it's how often we say it you guys notice
i repeat [ __ ] over and over and over and
over again on this show there's a reason
for it it [ __ ] works
it [ __ ] works it [ __ ] works it
[ __ ] see see
see what i mean
no obstruction no collusion no
obstruction no collusion build a wall
build a wall lock her up lock her up it
ain't about the three words it ain't
about the cute little quippy phrase
that's not what it is it's repetition
and rachel said it that's what sometimes
the strategic outrage is repetition
repetition repetition and you have to
hammer them and hammer them and hammer
them
and we have to find an issue that the
[ __ ] country will be outraged about
we have to find it and we have to beat
that message to death
and continue to pound that message in
the brains of
likely americans that will more than
likely vote
so they understand what the messaging
that charlie kirk is trying to say when
he says sexual anarchy he means hate
black people
you saw rachel show that
charlie kirk isn't talking about
sexuality
i mean they are obsessed with people's
genitalia but it's only to demonize
other people
who have certain types of genitalia or
want certain types of genitalia
most americans aren't worried about
other people's [ __ ] genitalia they're
not in a general basis most americans
just want to go to work make their
[ __ ] money go home
watch reality tv have dinner make sure
they don't go [ __ ] broke if there's a
medical bill be able to retire so they
can do all that stuff without working at
some point in their lives that's what
they want they want to raise their
families they want to be happy they want
to be healthy they want to not run out
of money and not run out of food or
shelter
it really is not [ __ ] complicated
but when you go to these white suburban
areas and you're like oh
those scary sexual anarchists that were
on the halftime show
did you see them those spooky terror
sexual anarchist
has racial undertones
you've seen the racial undertones from
ben shapiro [ __ ] i'll pull it up if i
have to here
let's see if we can find this
yep here's the
here is the uh let's make this bigger
here there it is
you want to know what charlie kirk was
trying to say see what ben shapiro says
and know that's what he was trying to
say
snoop dogg collaborated on a song in
january with the following lyrics
right this goes back to the joe rogan
[ __ ]
these fragile white men are terrified
terrified
of this type [ __ ] snoop dogg
collaborated on a song in january
all you n words out there take your guns
that you're using to shoot each other
and start shooting these bitch-ass
[ __ ] police
that'll impress [ __ ] n words
like me
i wonder if i wonder if ben shapiro's
tweet here is a little racially
motivated he's quote tweeting
you consider west coast gangsta rap and
eminem to have racial leftist radical
messaging
look snoop dogg
and and rappers
in this country have been saying [ __ ]
the police for 40 years
40 years they've been saying [ __ ] the
police if that's a retic radical leftist
message
you people missed it a long [ __ ] time
ago the reason why they say that isn't
because they're radical leftists it's
because they were being killed by
[ __ ] cops
why do you think eminem took the [ __ ]
knee you dumb [ __ ]
ben shapiro this racist piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and all he's doing here is he's trying
to get everyone to talk about the n-word
again and how snoop dogg says it
and how it's okay for white people to
say it if it's okay for black people to
say it that's what he's saying
and that's a leftist message
and this is what rachel's talking about
when they try to interrupt our culture
with their culture messaging
so we have to we have to fight back
with our messaging
we have to continue to fight back
that the guy in in the sweat suit that
was that was rapping
at the super bowl
at the super bowl
in a sweatsuit after he just got done
smoking weed
that guy
that guy is not going to come to your
suburbs
and take your suburbs away
that's what [ __ ] ben shapiro is
trying to say they're coming for you
you heard it when the [ __ ] cheeto
dust mobster try to run in 2020. they're
gonna come take your suburbs they're
gonna destroy your suburbs
these [ __ ] fragile white people don't
understand that black people and people
color are
have large percentage of the suburbs
they live there they're part of the
community
they're hard working members of those
communities
earning wages paying taxes
supporting their economy you know by
going to restaurants gas stations
and retail stores
but they want to scare people
they want to scare people with this
language
and it's their strategic outrage that
they have with lies
but we can do it with truth
you've seen rachel talk about it we can
do it with truth we don't have to do it
with lies we do it truth
there's a few republicans willing to do
that now they're being cast away
like liz cheney and adam kenyon of
course you know my feeling on them but
while they're digging the grave for
fascist
especially trumpism and trump himself
don't take the shovel out of their hands
so we have to continue to fight because
it's worth fighting for democracy is
worth fighting for but that's what all
this stuff is that's what this [ __ ]
of course i'm gonna give
ben shapiro here credit you suck and so
does your [ __ ] tweet you little [ __ ]
yes i want to tweet that [ __ ]
you racist [ __ ]
what in the hell what in the hell does
these lyrics have anything to do about
radical leftist
ideology
this is the same stupid [ __ ] when they
say
that somehow three brothers are trying
to take down joe rogan it's a big huge
conspiracy cabal
because they're jewish
that's why that's why that's why they're
that's why the right wing and the
stoolies
and the joe roganites
are after the myzelis brothers of midas
touch
it's the same old trope the same old
racist fascist [ __ ]
i mean you even seen dave portnoy
during the interview talk about
kaepernick
enter the chat with kaepernick and and
the halftime show with eminem
which i find it funny again that the nfl
or anyone decided that they would tell
eminem what the [ __ ] to do or tell him
what not to do more specifically and
thought that he would not do that
what the [ __ ]
that's hilarious
and the other thing that they were
pissed off about is is dr dre not
leaving out the lyrics that they still
wanna they still wanna kill the police
and ben shapiro's really [ __ ]
frustrated with that too
obviously here
and this is their culture war
the people who stormed the capital to
overthrow the constitution of the united
states by killing police with american
beating and killing police with american
flags and blue live matter flags are the
ones that are going to [ __ ] tell
leftists
what policies they should have on police
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
that's what the messaging needs to be oh
the pro police people are pro killing
police as long as the police are trying
to prevent them from overthrowing the
government of the united states of
america
they're so pro-police
when they can't even vote
to make sure that those police officers
that protected congress protected the
capital and protected our constitution
they can't even vote to honor those
police officers those pro-police get the
[ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
right-wing fascist agenda they don't
want the police they want their own
police they want their own fascist state
they want their own fascist militias
that's what the oath keepers were that's
what the proud boys are
that's what adam waffen is the neo-nazi
group who has infiltrated parts of our
military and law enforcement
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
that you oh you you hate police it's
a hating police is a leftist agent get
the [ __ ] out of here
again we have to beat back with
messaging
they're the ones who are anti-police
black people just don't want to be
killed by police because they're black
that's it
black people aren't scared of police
they don't hate police they just don't
want to be killed by them
because of the color of their skin
it's not complicated it really isn't
the only people who want to defund and
take away the police are republicans
they're the ones who voted to defund
them the only people who voted to fund
the police in the last year and a half
is democrats that's it full stop
they're the only ones that have voted
for police
so this idea that snoop dogg
saying these lyrics in january is some
kind of democrat agenda you are a dumb
[ __ ] and he knows what he's
doing ben shapiro's knows what he's
doing he's using race and he's using
fear to get racist white people all
riled up to think that oh my god we
gotta back the blue i mean as long as
the blue is on our side to overthrow the
government of the united states and
create a fashion state
so [ __ ] ben shapiro and anyone who looks
like ben shapiro and [ __ ] charlie kirk
and anyone who looks like charlie kirk
[ __ ] him
he's [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] out there
running their [ __ ] game trying to
[ __ ]
be as racist as they possibly can be
without having to [ __ ] say it because
again there was a lot of these [ __ ]
right-wing fragile white males that got
their account suspended there the racist
trolls were out i mean they were
everywhere typing in the n-word i mean
it was [ __ ] vile it was [ __ ] gross
and they were everywhere on twitter i
mean
the the black guys playing football no
trigger as soon as as soon as a black
dude in a sweatsuit is smoking a joint
and then he comes on stage and starts
singing into the microphone [ __ ] we're
triggered they were triggered as a
[ __ ]
triggered as a [ __ ]
and it's because of [ __ ] like this
that racists like this type out on the
internet and they say into microphones
that's right i'm calling ben shapiro a
racist
someone go [ __ ] tell him tag him in
that [ __ ]
i don't give a [ __ ]
[ __ ] him
okay let's let's see one more piece of
news we're 51 this has been a great a
great show today we had um we
we had a special guest with us
from from really news now
um um carly carly shirk
and then we had rachel bitkoffer
um fantastic when we have rachel i know
everyone loves rachel that was the
comments um everyone loves rachel loves
when she talks about fascists and
smashing fascists
um
i i think i think
maybe the the activity of punching nazis
might be rachel's favorite
i know it's a favorite for all of you
guys out there um you know i'm not
saying i'm not i'm not promoting i'm
just saying that maybe if you've seen a
video of it happening possibly on the
internet
you could you could be like yeah you
know that's cool
but thanks for joining us today i really
appreciate it again i want to remind you
every single weekday monday through
friday
we're we're on the youtubes
the tweety tweets the trendy trends
and the twitch
noon eastern 11 central every every
single weekday let's go one more time um
i want to mention um actually one thing
where i go i forget
uh parkland was trending earlier i think
this is another issue where
um we can um
talk about for messaging
let's go over here now we can talk about
for messaging here
is the parkland uh anniversary
because as you know since the parkland
shooting at stoneman douglas high school
happened
a lot of things good has happened in
some states but in some red states
it has gone in the opposite direction
like in states like texas where
basically anyone and everyone can have a
gun now any dangerous [ __ ] can
have a gun and you know frankly they
encourage it because they won't want to
have background checks
but i encourage you to go to this thread
make this a little bigger and look at
some of the messages here
um and and and see
see
see the truth
and the truth is
that this
school shooting that happened down in
parkland
um as as
or ordinary and routine as it is now is
very significant and the reason why it's
significant is because a lot of a lot of
good people decided to fight back
against
against gun violence and against
just free reign of guns in this country
and have some sort
of reasonable
gun reform so that way
children didn't get killed in schools
and if you want an education message
you want to talk about messaging and
education how about let's not let our
kids get killed while they're trying to
trying to do school how about that
that's a pretty good [ __ ] message
let's make sure our kids are safe in
schools
away from gun violence and that's pretty
good messaging i think i think it's a
winning message as well and not only
that let's [ __ ] protect our children
from these
these [ __ ] gq peers who want to
inundate them with bullets
because that's what they want they want
oh they don't don't doubt me
don't doubt me that's what they want
they want more guns more bullets in the
schools
one gun and and um
a handful of high-capacity magazines is
not enough bullets and not enough guns
they want more they want the teachers to
have them they want the they want the
janitors to have them they want the
students to have them they want everyone
to have guns more bullets more guns
means more death but you know it's more
profit
so that's important more profit is
important because you know buying the
guns and buying the ammo buying the high
magazine rounds
buying the assault weapons the weapons
of war that's all profit i mean the [ __ ]
[ __ ] having kids be safe in education
facilities right and being educated and
get get down to the learning
that's what they want that's the message
that's what you have to send
they don't care they don't give a [ __ ]
they don't give a [ __ ] about education
they never did never will
they care about gun pro they care about
gun manufacturers profits they give a f
they give a real big [ __ ] about that
i mean how the hell would they raise
money if they weren't raised from a
bunch of [ __ ] gun nuts
how would they send a message if they
couldn't send a message admiral dead
hands obama's gonna take your guns
hillary's gonna take your goon biden
going today i'm taking one [ __ ] gun
not [ __ ] one
so remember this day four years marks
the day of the
shooting in parkland
at
florida
marjory stoneman douglas high school
let's not forget this
and let's not [ __ ] up the messaging on
this because it's there
and it looks like there's some news
um it looks like
looks like um they're protesting on some
kind of tower so i'm gonna
i'm gonna investigate that here's david
hogg let's listen to this video real
quick we got a few minutes i want to see
what's going on here now i probably
missed this let's see
has currently scaled a crate he's up
there with a mural of his son hanging
from and joaquin who died in the
parkland shooting in 2018 along with 17
other students and administrators manuel
oliver is an advocate for gun violence
prevention he is up there today
demanding change with the wine
administration for them to do everything
that they possibly can to address gun
violence and stop the next part that's
happening before it does if you'd like
to support his work go to stock market
stockmarket.org
to see the impact of the number of
people that have died and been injured
by guns
in the time since biden has taken office
once again that is shockmarket.org if
you'd like to take action with us text
now this is this is a decent um thing
and and i'm gonna retweet david here but
let me tell you something this is this
is what rachel's talking about this is
the off messaging this is the off
messaging it is not it is not joe
biden's fault of the democrats fault
that there's not gun reform
that's not that's not the that's not
that's all [ __ ]
that's all [ __ ]
it's not it's not the democrats fault
that they that there's not
gun reform that will keep kids safe
there's been plenty of bills passed out
of the house
can't make it through the senate can't
make it to president biden's disc
how many [ __ ] bills do you think
president biden would sign if they made
it to the guest for gun safety and make
sure that kids kids aren't needlessly
[ __ ] murdered and schooled by weapons
of war how many
this is where we this is where we eat
ourselves this is where we cut the head
off our own selves
it's not democrats working against gun
safety
it's not blue states that are passing
walls that do away with background
checks completely give guns to everyone
no matter who they are what their
background it's not democratic states
it's not democratic controlled states
that are doing that it's not
stop stop stop doing that stop doing it
stop doing it
there's only one party in this country
that wants to make sure that children
aren't safe for the profit of gun
manufacturers
gun manufacturers profits are way
[ __ ] more important than children and
our citizens and our fellow americans
safety
way more important to them
let's get real
and ain't the democrats doing this
democrats deliver gun safety they've
done it over and over
in the states where they have control
and they would do it they would do it
over and over again in the federal
government and the president united
states right now would be signing those
laws
for gun safety not to take away guns to
make sure people aren't [ __ ]
killed by them students children little
children aren't killed in the safest
place that they're supposed to be their
school
let's make sure that messaging stays
where it needs to be
thanks for joining me today on the tony
michaels podcast
join me tomorrow same time same place
youtube twitter twitch noon eastern 11
central nine specif pacific until
tomorrow surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media
at the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking